Break Europe
this is what they mean and that's what they want
we certainly do not want to break Europe
first of all,
we distinguish between Europe
and the EU for us is Europe
an incredible diversity of cultures and peoples
in a very narrow space
dubious European policy means for us
that we always distinguish between diversity on the one hand
and the headquarters in Brussels on the one hand have to weigh up
what can the peoples themselves
and what must Brussels do
and there we are the only
because all the other parties always just want more
Brussels and we say let's look closely
and we find now is the time
that we also have competences back to the citizen
and give into the regional communities
because it is simply more democratic
and becomes more transparent
but they say
you should pull the plug in uh at the EU
make everything so to speak uh
everything new
everything again at the beginning well there we do not say
we say
we want to reform it and then comes this sentence
if reforming doesn't work out at all
then we press reset
pull the plug but also put it back in
and rebuild it
but the try
that we want to make and for which I am competing
is of course a reform
by saying
let's see
what belongs to Brussels
and what belongs to the peoples and to the citizens
and there is some
what you can certainly rules below